tu es une femme extraordinaire jeanne
si je vous dis que vous êtes la femme de
l'année mettez la femme du siècle
ouailles j'ai beaucoup menteuse il lui
est arrivé quoi déjà la fin de l'année
vous êtes un poil de la faillite
personnelle des cdl vous lycées des
biens un appartement à lisbonne moi je
vous dirais de vendre cet appartement
hu à la tronche ça se trouve tu vas être
assise à côté lui d'un avion
à tous les coups y venir te voir
pee wee bb bb bb b
j'aime on se connaît bah oui tu te
souviens pas un
aucun souvenir en tout cas c'est pas du
tout des ses ventes et ses marges
seraient toujours pensé que ça allait
mourir jeune je suis très content de
voir que tu es en vie
voici les clés ne les perd pas sur le
pont des soupirs
ouais genre ces jeunes
non on ne sait jamais foncia et moi j'ai
rendez vous avec un agent immobilier as
tu m'entendras parte ou que tu vois je
suis surendetté à un félicitations
[Musique]
tu vas me montrer comment tu fais des
cartons c'est ça qu'il faut faire pour
l'être au bien manger
un peu toc toc un jeune mère sera pas
des ragots j'aime bien non mais pas du
tout
[Musique]
moi je t'ai
is it c'est encore oui oui oui je sais
mais je remercie c'est une cigarette
électronique elle ne brûle pas tout va
bien
[Musique]